At the beginning of the lesson, we
promised that we would link up these two
chains and use the transitivity of
reductions to show that vertex cover and
independent set are NP-complete.
We now turn to the last
link in this chain, and
we'll reduce 3-CNF SAT
to independent set.
As we've already argued these
problems are N and P so
that will complete the proof
that they are NP-complete.
Here's the transformation, or
reduction, we need to accomplish.
The input is a 3-CNF formula, with M
clauses and we need to output a graph
that has an independent set of size m if
and only if the input is satisfiable.
We'll illustrate on this example.
For each literal in the formula
we create a vertex in a graph.
Then, we add edges between all vertices
that came from the same clause.
We'll refer to these as within clause
edges or simply the clause edges.
Then we add edges between all literals
that are contradictory, b and
b bar can't both be true for instance.
We refer to these as the between clause
edges or the contradiction edges.
The implementation of
this transformation
is simple enough to imagine, and I'll
leave it to you to convince yourself
that it can be done in polynomial time